[Applaudissements]
c'est un mec qui rentre il rentre dans
une banque il prend deux personnes en
otage donc la police le négociateur ils
essaient d'être calmez-vous monsieur
sortez dit non ma vie c'est de la merde
à cause de cette société je suis énervé
ou autre façon que j'ai buté un otage il
va il regarde la femme sa femme elle dit
enfin je regarde la femme il dit écoutez
je suis obligé de buter un otage
d'écouter bah il y a pas de problème de
micro vous appelez je m'appelle Béatrice
et là le mec il commence à pleurer il
pleure avec son flingue il pleure il me
prend vous pleurez mais parce que mon ex
s'appelait Béatrice la pauvre elle nous
a quitté et le mec à côté dis-moi je
m'appelle Marcel mais dans le quartier
on m'appelle Béatrice
[Applaudissements]
dans un autre style elle est on va dire
plus poétique
c'est de type sur bourrée et le premier
il fait ils sont au pied d'un lampadaire
il fait quoi
je te dis que ça ça c'est imaginaire tu
as besoin
la lune
c'est pas possible
ça c'est le soleil
je te dis que c'est
la lune moi je suis sur mes enfants que
ça c'est le soleil si tu continues à
contredire je vais te démolir
et au bout d'un moment il y a un mec qui
passe
on est pas d'accord tu peux nous aider
l'autre truc c'est pas de problème
je sais pas je suis pas du quartier
[Applaudissements]
qui sont copines donc Rebecca Rachel et
comment elle s'appelle ta mère voilà
très important pour la suite donc
Rebecca
je pouvais éviter les blagues
antisémites ce soir tu vas voir Rebecca
Rachel et serre donc ces trois copines
elles sont fier de leur fils parce
qu'ils gagnent plutôt bien leur vie et
tout et Rebecca elle dit moins de toute
façon les filles mon fils il est
tellement riche mais s'il veut et ben il
peut racheter tout Paris alors Rebecca
elle fait elle prend les boules un peu
donc elle dit moi Rebecca mon fils il
est tellement riche que si il veut il
peut racheter tout New York
et là il y a Esther qui dit les filles
qui vous a dit que mon fils vont
j'en ai une que j'adore j'adore cette
histoire j'adore c'est un TIP il vient
chez lui avec trois femmes
et ça ça
parce que je vais épouser l'une des
trois je voudrais que tu devines
laquelle c'est un millième un millième
de seconde elle fait celle du milieu il
fait comment ça deviner si vite en fait
c'est la seule que j'aime pas
[Applaudissements]